this comes after more than a year of
covet 19 restrictions and economic
hardships
madison kimbrough spoke with a local
restaurant owner who shares his thoughts
on making changes to his business
come june 1st madison
yeah sasha most of the people that we
spoke to are ready for a full reopen
however one restaurant owner raymie
mosca
is a bit hesitant as he believes people
still need to take precaution
take a look i know a lot of people is
celebrating that we are reopening and
all that but i want them to still
think that hey there is a pandemic there
and some places
it's not 100 under control local
restaurant owner raymie mosca
is pleased about vegas reopening at full
capacity but wants people to realize
that we still have a ways to go when it
comes to getting back to what we
consider
normal clark county local covent
mitigation plan expires june 1st
allowing the return of the pre-pandemic
guidelines that lift restrictions
involving capacity limits large
gatherings and more
mosca says he doesn't plan on changing
much at his restaurant but says
guidelines like mask wearing among his
staff
will stay in place along with spacing
out customers that choose to dine in
we have a large party we have we try to
split them in like
two or three tables memorial day weekend
serves as a reminder that many people
are ready for the 100 percent reopening
it feels great to be outdoors and like
out of the homes and around people again
it's a different feel
you're definitely you're it's like kind
of going back to normal but you still
feel you have to really be careful
starting june 1st fully vaccinated
people will no longer have to wear masks
or socially distance
in addition capacity limits will go away
county commissioners continue to
encourage people to get vaccinated and
if hospital capacity does rise
mitigation measures will be required so
make sure to look out for that
reporting live from the las vegas sign
madison kimbrough 8 news now